let's get in there real quick while you
guys start to eat we're talking about
the final four restaurants it's our big
pizza bracket for march madness of
course so here are the final four naked
city giordano's lucinos and dom demarcos
we're going to give a little bit of a
taste test and give you a flavor of what
flavor is working today right now i want
to pull it down though because this one
is the square cut which is kind of fun
so this is naked city okay naked city
pizza and we did cheese right we did
cheese kind of to make it to make it
even you've been playing no fair they
put bay leaves on that one
yeah so um
it's all a pizza for for march madness
what do you reckon this is heaven
heaven really good heaven pizza so this
is dom demarco's which one is that
lucino casino
that's huge that's like a piece of pie i
need a fork for that yeah cheesecake
this is a lot of stuff so i thought i
want to try that one oh yeah yeah
don't forget by the way
vote for uh vote for the final four for
march madness uh even though we're in
april now for the for the pizza bracket
tell us your favorite pizza place in
town we i think we this is bomb they're
all just so different okay wait so this
is chicago style yes right and then what
is considered new york style the
supposedly thinner crust i see this is
more grandma style thin
thin
cup yeah square cut gosh i'm learning so
much here
uh
jordano's mm-hmm
demarco all right the pizza bracket
the basil yeah on it it kind of just
gives that little extra so give it a
score out of ten score to ten real quick
well i've had this before so i i really
like naked city i do too oh i don't know
uh an eight
seven point
one i'm going to give a six it's good
but dom demarco's what do you reckon
okay i'll give it an eight all right
there you go
give us your scores vote for your own
pizza places on the pizza bracket
meanwhile the production crew is just
salivating right now behind the cameras
i can see it i know jared i feel i feel
kind of bad for you and a reminder you
have until saturday okay to uh vote for
the finalists until midnight naked city
versus lucinos and giordano's is going
up against dom demarcos then voting in
our final round begins sunday at noon
more good day las vegas and more beat
supplies after the break